bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors je viens de le dire
la coop 26 qui joue les prolongations
savez bien dire que les pays
participants on ne sont pas d'accord
qu'elle est la pomme de discorde
bah écoute et qui est important de
rappeler c'est que la coop va ainsi sa a
rappelé l'importance de des difficultés
liées aux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
ou comment dire ou aux énergies fossiles
pétrole gaz et charbon et là on est au
coeur je pense du questionnement puisque
une étude de harvard expliqué que les
émissions liées aux énergies fossiles
conduisait à 10 millions de morts par an
et donc on est au coeur de la
problématique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on le voit on a un départ
en europe sur la question de la
taxonomie c'est-à-dire l'introduction du
nucléaire dans la liste des activités
vertes et finalement la cop16 tenez bon
comme pas du tout la question de la
décarbonation parole le nucléaire donc
on est au vrai au coeur de la
problématique et la france a un apport
véritable danseuse dans cette
problématique puisque la france il ya
des meilleurs élèves au monde en termes
de décarbonation électrique est un
exemple à donner dans le monde avec ses
58 réacteurs nucléaires en action enfin
56 en enlevant fessenheim et donc on est
au coeur de la question est d'ailleurs
on le voit puisque le rapport du giec de
2018 avait exposé que et bien en 2018 le
fait qu'il fallait multiplié par deux ou
par six le nombre de réacteurs
nucléaires donc en fait je pense que la
cop16 ne règle pas la question parce
quand elle patine parce qu'en fait elle
ne va pas au coeur des sujets etc en
particulier à cause de l'allemagne qui
fait tout pour empêcher que la france
d'atteindre le nucléaire dans les
activités vers de la taxonomie
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron parlant du
nucléaire la non c'est un c'était mardi
lors de son discours 1 que la france
allait construire de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et régime que c'est un moyen
d'attendre la neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 mais aussi d'attendre de garantir
en tout cas l'indépendance énergétique
et c'est vrai qu'en en ce moment c'est
un vrai débat bah oui c'est un vrai
débat d'ailleurs la chine
emmanuel macron dans le bon chemin en
annonçant la création et la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
mais il suit le chemin
avancés par la chine qui vient
d'annoncer 150 réacteurs nucléaires pour
les prochaines années ou même de la
russie qui construit un nombre important
de réacteurs nucléaires faut le rappeler
à vos téléspectateurs le nucléaire a le
meilleur bilan carbone avec 6 grammes de
co2 par kilowattheure produit alors que
le charbon c'est mg par kilowattheure
produit et 500 grammes pour le gaz est
alors que justement le gouvernement et
le président thésaurus et dans un igloo
à restreindre l'accès au gaz en europe
on le voit bien la question de la remise
en oeuvre de centrales nucléaires en
france et non seulement un enjeu de
souveraineté énergétique mais aussi un
enjeu écologique avec un souci de
décarbonation et là probablement que la
coop 26 a loupé une occasion d'avancer
plus fort au niveau international dans
le cadre du rapport du giec qui avaient
été publiées en 2018 et c'est là où le
bât blesse à mon avis dans le cadre des
réflexions actuelles et en tout cas ce
qui est intéressant c'est que les
annonces des manuels macron annonce une
nouvelle donne en matière énergétique en
france dans ce choc face aux chocs
gazier que nous connaissons en europe
alors effectivement tout est un peu
brouillée mais globalement la france a
des atouts incontestables dans ce dans
ce nouveau jeu qui est en train de se
dessiner alors on sait que le nucléaire
fait débat et ceux qui le dénoncent
parle de trois problème un problème de
déchets de sécurité et de démantèlement
que leur répondez vous
écoutez je pense que je pense que les
contempteurs des lumières de verio mon
livre nucléaire les vérités cachées
parce que tout le monde a oublié que
nous avions eu un prix nobel de physique
en 2010 8 gérard mon groupe qui a trouvé
des solutions avec les lasers pour ta
pulsions pour accélérer le processus de
transmutation des déchets nucléaires
c'est à dire la baisse de la
radioactivité des déchets nucléaires que
les questions de sécurité depuis
tchernobyl n'ont eu de cesse au niveau
international de se perfectionner
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
la construction de fessenheim direct
repères de fessenheim beaucoup plus long
que prévu parce que justement on fait
ensemble de promouvoir tous les systèmes
de sécurité les plus importantes qu'il
ya eu des progrès gigantesques sur la
question des sécurité nucléaire et de la
sûreté nucléaire et concernant les
déchets nucléaires est bien la france
avait à rester astrid qui était le
recteur à neutrons rapides qui
permettait justement de baisser et de
supprimer la radioactivité des déchets
est clair et le président macron là et
c'est une grosse erreur la lgv est
annulée en 2019 alors que justement bill
gates aux états unis est en train
aujourd'hui avec le département de
l'énergie américain de promouvoir ce
réacteur à neutrons rapides dans le
wisconsin et que justement la chine et
la russie justement qui sont les autres
pays très appliqués dans le nucléaire
sont en train de développer une
technologie de réacteurs à neutrons
rapides donc on le voit les
antinucléaires aujourd'hui sont
totalement has been est un peu dépassé
par les événements parce que la
recherche scientifique
vassa leurs fausses informations
montrent qu'en réalité il ya des progrès
considérables en la matière qui je vous
le rappelle il ya énormément de
personnalités écologistes qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de se rallier
à la cause nucléaire je pense à yann
arthus bertrand qui a fait un coming out
pro-nucléaire monsieur val le l'ancien
patron de charlie hebdo des
personnalités comme monsieur michael
sirène berger aux états unis des
scientifiques allemands la patronne de
zion light patronne de zion light deux
extinctions rébellion donc partout dans
le monde il ya eu prise en compte du
fait que le nucléaire par l'élément
décarbonés constitue une solution pour
la planète mais aussi constitue un
élément de souveraineté énergétique et
donc de souveraineté nationale et donc
pour la france c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire mais je pense qu emmanuel
macron ne va pas assez loin dans son
plan surtout dans le fait qu'il l'a
n'arrête pas les renouvelables comme les
éoliennes ou les panneaux
photovoltaïques qui doivent être
compensé par du gaz et ça à mon avis
c'est un point sensible qu'il devra
corriger par les mois qui viennent
fabien bouglé merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions rappelle vous êtes
spécialiste en énergie auteur d'un livre
nucléaire la vérité est cachée merci à
vous